it's important that I just put myself
100 apply myself and represent you know
the young black man whatever I do more
importantly that then you know let's get
something real meaty real political I
really just want to put myself make make
myself being political by having my
principles living by my principles and
applying myself to today's society what
do you want from me
think you call the fly you can see it in
one thing when I'm down there with the
equipment those were real tears as soon
as they I started tapping there it was
like it could come up every time because
just I know how important the music can
be to the getting getting over and
getting along in your life I know how
the music can heal people solve it could
be a difference between life and death
men themselves have wondered what they
see in me they try so much but they
can't touch my inner mystery what do you
think about all this attention it's
funny they didn't know me a little while
ago I'm gonna have to work she see more
money in her life than she ever had each
job I take I feel like it's different
than the last one each character is
different than the last one each movie
is different than the last one there's
no comparison it gives me a certain
amount of freedom in my music bit and
the music that I do and just in general
as a young black male to have you know
the opportunity to do movies where I can
get money and you know getting a certain
spot in white Hollywood I I don't think
I have fans I think they like it my
friends you know people that can relate
to it they feel like when they see me in
the role it's going to be real they feel
like if Tupac's name is in it it's gonna
be a real movie I'm gonna be real no
matter what it's going to be real all
the time you do that because uh
if you don't me and you gonna have
problems you understand you could be one
kind of an artist you could be another
kind of an artist I want to be an
exceptional artist and I want to be here
for the longevity you know I want to be
when it's over I want it to be more than
just for the beats and the bass lines I
want it to be for something I want to
stand for something you know I don't
want to be just a regular statistic you
know what I'm saying I wanna I wanna
break them all so everybody's saying how
they can't do it I want to do it and
then when I do it watch everybody do it
then I go back to Thug and fully again
you know what I'm saying but right now
I'm a show I'm listening to what
everybody's saying but it seems like the
whole country is saying everybody's is
losing people everybody's at the
cemetery you know what I'm saying that's
where you can do your best business so I
want to see what I could do to change
and if I can and if it don't work then
you know I go another route but this is
just one thing I want to try I got
something called me against the world
perfect for all this perfect me against
the world it's just
got nothing to lose it's just me against
the world
[Music]
but I'm a nice person I'm a thug my
survival I have to be to survive not
because I want to be I don't want to
hurt nobody you know what I'm saying I
want to be I want to survive I want to
make money I want to be in business I
want to do it but what's honest about
the world is that no one's going to let
me do that so that's where the thug
comes in but if everybody just left me
alone I'll be a nice person you ever
feel like you're luck's running out man
I mean
lately I've been feeling like my luck's
been running out
a lot of people have an image about you
what would you like them to know about
you in 1996 Tupac now that I'm a Gemini
me being a Gemini I am I am the classic
case of a Gemini you know what I mean no
what does that mean it means that I'm
quiet I could be calm quiet and very
into my work and totally focused and
totally disciplined and um boring you
know what I mean or I could be fun fun
but dangerous dangerous dangerous not
only to other people but to myself
because I'm I'm like a kid in a candy
store all of this is new I'm 25 you know
I mean and it's like got cash everything
you dreamed of and they've held me back
in so many other circumstances that now
it's your time to go and it's kind of
hard difficult to keep yourself from
just pressing the gas down all the way
basically just taking my time and
thinking and analyzing situations and
trying to think before I do things I'm
very passionate Gemini's you know me and
Prince
and how do you deal with the pressures
you see it you see it on the news all
the time how I deal with it I deal with
it like um like I think any human being
would deal with it is like people can
tell you you know don't do this or don't
do that but my my whole mind state is
that if we don't ever go outside of the
boundaries we will never change anything
we will never begin anything we'll never
start anything we'll just keep talking
about the people who did it once and
told us not to go outside the thing
that's just like I'm telling Christopher
Columbus that the world is flat you know
I mean I'm doing the same thing they're
telling me you can't do this you can
only rap and if you rap you can only rap
about this then you can you can't act
and if you act you can only do the black
films and you know you can't be a rap
you can't be a artist or a celebrity and
go out still and you can't be an artist
and still have fun and still be true I
don't like that so I try to go outside
the boundary sometimes it's effective
and it's positive sometimes it's
negative and it blows off my face my
fine mistakes were on the news you know
what I mean everybody has five mistakes
they did maybe three maybe four I've
done about five things that are
questionable things that you know I
should not have done but now it's just
like like the Reebok effect I do one
thing and it comes out three times I can
never change how people see me I can
only try to be better at what I do so
that when they do blow it up it's you
know it doesn't look as bad I don't know
if I've changed I've just grown you know
what I mean I might still make the same
mistakes but it'll be something
different about it because I learned
from every time I fall on my on my
behind I learned on like you know
there's something there watch out for
the banana peel and the floor is
slippery but you still don't know
everything like I might know not to walk
on the floor because I might slip but I
don't know not to touch the electric
socket and I get shocked you know what I
mean so the only way you can learn is
Hands-On you know and sometimes that's
shocking and hurts but sometimes you put
your hand on something good like money
or you know gold or reward or an album
or some good material or a good movie
from taking that same chance that got
you in trouble life is funny ain't it
somehow I don't think this was my
parents dream for me so why did you
decide to do this movie what did you
like about it to help change my image
really number one this movie is really
about friendship and what unconditional
friendship means and I did it basically
because it was funny and I've never got
to really be funny now that I'm I mean I
might not be funny
I got a couple jokes I got a couple
jokes I met Eddie Griffin one time Chris
Tucker I met them they gave me a joke
each I carry a joke with you so I got
you know but after two I got to go get
some new materials so you're gonna do a
romantic comedy anytime soon we're gonna
see too far serenading a girl no doubt
working on my little production company
movie production company we got a lot of
a lot of good things happening so I'm
just if I say it right now the way my
luck has been going it'll all fall
through but if I said it you go oh
that's really nice but just give me a
month just so I can lock it down did I
tell everybody but it's good stuff I
just want to push the envelope and work
work I want to move further away from
the music and go and start waning myself
into the acting more
[Music]
it's emotional but it's not thought
provoking so I want to do some
thought-provoking work with my music and
I can do that if I'm working in the
fields because I grow and learn more
things and have more to talk about but
if you in jail you're getting chased by
the police it's like I haven't gone
anywhere from the Block as I'm still
talking about the same things you know
what I mean so the music reflects that
so first I gotta move out of the
environment and then I have other things
to write about what is this trying to
bring back 1989. I was poor in 1989 you
know I was in jail so now we out trying
to show prosperity and hope and the
future
[Music]